gaetanos has been a Henderson staple for
the past 20 years and this Friday you
can taste the world at their wine dinner
here to tell us more is Nick and Sarah
palmari the owners of gaetanos welcome
how you doing I'm so excited you guys
are on the show such a legendary
restaurant 20 years in Henderson give
everyone the history of the backstory of
the restaurant absolutely so
um Gaetano is my father he was a
restaurant tour from Italy and we had
our original location in Calabasas
California for 20 years we sort of got
sick of California sold it moved to
Henderson in the early 2000s and the
restaurant's been there since 2002. and
that's our that's our game that's
Henderson's and Las Vegas's game because
there's so many great things about the
restaurant and what's happening on
Friday night this is a special event
yeah so Friday night we do wine dinners
every single month so Friday night we're
doing a taste of the world wine dinner
which is something a little different
that we usually do so we typically do
Italian wines and domestic wines but
we're actually doing Old World Wines for
that dinner and Sarah what are some of
the wines that you guys have featured on
Friday night so we have uh bubbly from
California that we're going to have with
a Frito misto we have a single Vineyard
Chardonnay that's going to be with our
pasta course and then I'm really excited
we're doing two wines head to head with
our main course okay
you know when we were trying once we try
all the wines together in the restaurant
to make sure that they really go with
the food and he preferred one and I
preferred the other you're not gonna say
which one nobody is right now we're not
gonna say which ones that we're doing
them as a Face-Off so we have uh Rioja
Grand Reserva and we have a Bordeaux as
well I love the passion that you guys
have for wine and for the restaurant and
also for our community as well we have
some more wine in front of me and this
is extra special because the holidays
are coming up maybe you're going to a
dinner party you're going to see family
what do you bring I had this issue on
Thanksgiving well It's Tricky right
because you look at that wall of wine
yeah you think where do I even start I
got about 45 seconds so maybe pick out
your dude if you are going somewhere or
just panic because you are having people
over you cannot go wrong with bubbly
that's it bottle Prosecco great your hit
okay you can mix it with cocktails you
can have for breakfast I like how you're
drinking
breakfast
um or a bottle of Rose okay again that's
going to go with uh Rose doesn't have a
season you can alert your rose all day
every day all day every day is that a
shirt yet I know Rose all day is one
rose day all day every day is gonna be
our shirt there we go I love it well
Nick and Sarah thank you so much for
joining us and what's the website to get
tickets for Friday night um actually you
call the restaurant at
702-361-1661 or uh email us at info
gaetanoslasvegas.com it's going to be an
event thank you guys for joining us
thank you so much Jillian we'll send it
over to you can you